All right.
Now to
this surprising discovery
that is defying the laws of science.
Crowds are flocking
to the small
town of Gower, Missouri,
to view a Catholic nun's body
that appears to show no signs of decay
despite being buried for four years.
The body of Sister Wilhemina Lancaster,
who died in 2019 at the age of 95,
was exhumed
from the monastery grounds
so that she could be moved to her
final resting place inside the chapel.
But when her coffin was unearthed,
this is what they found.
Lancaster's body
was apparently incorrupt,
which in Catholic tradition
means the body did not decay.
CNN affiliate KMBC reports
people have traveled
from across the country
to see for themselves
Powerful
experience, very powerful.
It's one of the most rare events
in the whole United States.
Not that old,
but I've never heard of that in my life.
Well, let me bring in Kelsey Wilkes.
She is the executive director
for the HCI group
and has written about this
for the Catholic News Agency.
Kelsey, good to see you.
Thank you for having me.
So walk us through exactly
what this group of
sisters found when they unearthed
the body.
Well, it's really remarkable, Fredricka.
When I sat down with the ABC,
she said, you know,
we began to exhume
the body of our founders
to move her into the chapel.
It's a longstanding custom
in Catholic religious orders
to have your founders, founders
or founders and your in your chapel
and as we were exhuming her,
there was a crack in the coffin.
And so she took a flashlight look ten.
And she goes, I think I saw soot.
And she said she couldn't
have seen a foot
at this point in the game.
There should be a great deal
of decomposition.
They were expecting
to find skeletal remains
and instead they found an intact body.
So she said to her sisters,
I found a site and they all cheered,
knowing, of course, what
this potentially means
in Catholic tradition.
And so you actually went as well, right?
You went to see for yourself
and you and a whole
lot of people can see for themselves
because she is out in the open.
And what did you experience?
I mean, it was remarkable,
the level of detail.
Even the brand name of her sock
was still visible
the veil of her habit
was made of the same material
as the interior lining of the coffin,
and that had decayed
while the veil had not.
There was no smell of putrid or decay
or anything of this.
It was
it was just simply looked
as though she had been dead for a day.
It was really remarkable.
And so help people understand, you know,
in the terms of Catholicism,
what is incorruptible?
What does it mean?
Does she seem to demonstrate
everything that it embodies?
There's there does
need to be
a thorough investigation to make sure
that this is
was a case of an incorruptible
But what it essentially means
is that there's there's
a lack of natural process of decay.
And that points to a theological reality,
which is that you know, at this at this
at the end of this life,
there is something more.
And so people who demonstrate
extraordinary levels of holiness
within Catholicism often found
to have these incorrupt bodies,
which suggests that there's
some level of closeness
to the future resurrection
that they might have
Is there anything more
you can tell us about who
Sister Wilhemina Lancaster was?
Yeah, she was 95 when she died.
She lived 75 years
in religious life
under the vows
of poverty, chastity and obedience,
which is its own miracle.
And at the age of 70,
she founded this congregation
of Benedictine Sisters.
They're known for their
chart-topping Gregorian Chant albums,
but they've also now become known
for the body of this woman
in an unnatural state of decay.
And who is giving hope to Catholics
and non-Catholics
around the country that maybe God is
is active.
Wow. So.
So what comes next for Sister Wilhelmina?
I mean,
what will the process
look like to determine
if she, in fact, is an incorruptible
Know what
what does it take to ultimately
be declared a saint?
Well,
first, on the level of incorruptibility,
it doesn't necessarily demonstrate
the holiness of her life,
although it could be a sign of it.
So in order for her to be canonized,
she'll have to go through a process
that will begin
after the fifth year of her death,
that will go through
all of her writings, her
her virtues, her life
to see if there's anything in there
that is contradictory to the Christian
Christian way.
And then after that,
she'll need two miracles,
one miracle for beatification
and one miracle for canonization.
And this
this miracle, if it if it is found to be
not as a result of any sort of fluke
of the way
in which
she was buried,
or that the conditions within the ground,
which it does not appear
to be,
would not count for either
of those two miracles. Hmm.
And what do you know about how she
was prepared for burial?
So the abbess told me, and
it's been confirmed
by the person
who signed her death
certificate that she was not involved
and that she was laid in a simple coffin
and without a concrete sarcophagus
around it
and placed into the ground in Siena,
did a series of interviews
with morticians around the country.
And many of them
expressed their shock
at the fact that a body
that was not involved
would be at this point of lack of decay.
It's rather remarkable,
according to those that study
mortuary science.
Wow. Is remarkable.
That's why
so many people are flocking there
to see for themselves.
And apparently
there is a process that she'll you know,
the body will actually be
going through this week. Right.
I mean, there'll be
a rosary involving her sisters and what
else do you know?
So there
what's fascinating is
there will be 20,000 visitors
by the end of this weekend.
They are anticipating.
So they've had to set up a whole meet
and greet system.
They have porta potties
down on the property.
There are people in lines,
the volunteers
feeding them
just to be able to walk through
and catch a glimpse of
of sister's body
and to pray in front of it.
And on the 29th
the sisters will hold a rosary procession
and then they will formally move her body
into a glass
enclosed, enclosed case
and put her final remains
inside the chapel with the sisters
while they wait
to build a shrine to Saint Joseph
where they hope to bury her.
Wow, that's incredible.
And then potentially other
things could happen within the next year
because you mentioned the whole,
you know, fifth year after one's death,
potentially the process of canonization,
if it comes to that.
So wow, what a journey.